[Musik]
[Applaus]
jahren schaue ich sie ziemlich alle
videos von extremsportlern nicht
fallschirmspringen die bassdrum von
irgendwelchen gebäuden wingsuit den berg
herunter oder fallschirm von
heißluftballons oder aus dem flugzeug
von außen sieht es auch schon die
perfekte mischung eines parasiten
adrenalin kicks absoluter freiheit und
irgendwie ist es einfach beides mit
seinem komischen rucksack aus 4000 meter
höhe aber wie schwer ist das ganze und
vor allem was muss passieren damit ich
komplett alleine ohne an jemand anderen
fest gebunden zu sein aus dem flugzeug
springen ihr könnt es euch schon denken
genau das werden wir in diesem video
herausfinden viel spaß mit ich habe in
24 stunden fallschirmspringen gelernt
[Musik]
kramer 1 der ausbildung ich bin auf dem
weg zu gold in der nähe von berlin
werden heute direkt über zehn stunden
theorie alles glattgeht springe ich
morgen das erste mal aus dem flugzeug
und wenn ich das richtig verstehe ich
war noch nie in tandem sprung gemacht
gar nichts mehr noch nie aus dem
flugzeug gesprungen würde das bedeuten
dass mein allererster sprung aus dem
flugzeug ich und einen rucksack mit
einem fallschirm ich würde glaube ich
morgen alleine direkt aus dem flugzeug
springen
wir sind wirklich sofort rein gestartet
theorie über theorie stunde um stunde
und megageil seit langem nochmal in so
ein komplett neues thema einzutauchen
irgendwas was ich vorher wirklich noch
nie gemacht
erste pause erst einheit ist durch ich
muss wirklich sagen meine anspannung
schwindet von minute zu minute weil ich
anfange das thema zu verstehen welche
anfange zu verstehen wie das alles
funktioniert werden wir in den nächsten
tagen halten mega die teilen alles genau
verstehen wind verhalten auswirkungen
und so weiter und ich glaube dass ich
mich so einfach immer weiter heran
tasten kann und mit natürlichen gesunden
um nötigen respekt aber ohne angst dann
vielleicht morgen an den ersten sprung
trauen kann obwohl ich mich natürlich
gerade noch weit entfernt davon erstmal
vorweg was für einen komischen rucksack
haben wieder an und viel wichtiger noch
was ist da eigentlich drin auf jeden
fall mehr als gedacht nicht nur einer
sondern zwei fallschirme zwei
vollwertigen fallschirme ein hauptschirm
und der reserveschirm das war mir vorher
überhaupt nicht bewusst und ich werde
euch gleich noch erklären wofür der
reserveschirm da ist auch wenn es der
name schon so ein bisschen erklärt
ausgelöst wird der hauptschirm über den
teilen tut was dieses kleine ding ist
das ist diese typische bewegung die man
vom fallschirmspringen kennt jemand
hinten an seinem rucksack schmeißt diese
kleine ding raus und er zieht dann mit
25 bis 35 kilo den hauptschirm aus dem
rucksack den man auch container nennen
über die nächsten könig sekunden öffnet
sich dann der hauptschirm im besten fall
ohne komplikationen allerlei ein tourist
beschädigungen oder allgemeinen ebene
anderen eröffnungs probleme also das
erst mal grundsätzlich dazu was sich im
rucksack befindet und wie sich der
fallschirm abschnitt nachdem wir dann
wieder eine menge theorie hatten ging's
endlich ersten praktischen übung die
falschen ausbildung war aber gar nicht
der einzige grund warum ich nach berlin
gefahren bin timeless mein partner hat
er auch ein event und da was völlig
neues für mich vorbereitet so freunde
wir sind beim timeless event in berlin
angekommen hier werden alle collectibles
ausgestellt die über die letzten monate
hätte kaufen können oder noch kaufen
könnt heute wird ein mega gutes ding
vorgestellt ich weiß natürlich schon
bescheid wir schauen uns das gleich aber
gemeinsam haben jetzt schauen wir
erstmal ein bisschen humor ich hab mich
dann ist es super über streng limitierte
course figuren einen echten
unterschriebenen michael schumacher im
sammelkarten verschiedenste arten und so
ziemlich allem was cool aber als zu
teuer ist um es alleine schaffen zu
können war auch ein bild von frau
ausgestellt und grau selber war auch da
was ist zu dem zeitpunkt aber noch nicht
wusste als kleines dankeschön dafür dass
ich die idee in den raum geworfen habe
ein bild von by tommys fraktion
analysieren habe ich von timeless
gemeinsam ein nfc und eindruck des nff
unterschrieben von klopp beim event
übergeben bekommen was mich riesig
gefreut
da ist es wird in ehren gehalten und es
steht im set plötzlich meine
altersvorsorge also auch hier nochmal
riesen dank an alle beteiligten
besonders anteil lässt bei denen ihr
nach wie vor über den ersten link in der
video beschreibung als neukunde 10 euro
startguthaben bekommt mit dem ihr euch
direkt einen kostenlosen anteil eines
welcome erst sichern können zur auswahl
an welcome es entstehen gerade eine
operative rolle und einen nike sp
citigroup ziemlich gecheckt dass auf
jeden fall aus ich bedanke mich vielmals
sehr coole partnerschaft sehr cooles
event jetzt geht es weiter mit der
ausbildung
bevor wir auch nur irgendwas anziehen
checken wir erst mal alles auf
beschädigt willigen alle sachen an und
machen einen 3 x 3 x 3 check weil wir
drei mal drei sachen kontrolle
angefangen bei allen guten sind sie alle
fest sind sie nicht verdreht dann alles
was direkt mit dem fallschirm in
verhandlung treten gibt der serbe
stimmen alte meter all diese punkte
werden nicht nur einmal sondern im
hangar vor dem flugzeug im flugzeug von
mir selber und auch während der
ausbildung von meinem ausbilder noch mal
gecheckt um absolut sicher zu gehen dass
alles da ist und wirklich funktioniert
wie verhält man sich im flugzeug wie
steigt man richtig aus ohne andere zu
gefährden und welche positionen nehmen
wir einen um stabil zu fallen was
unheimlich essentiell ist welche übungen
machen wir in der luft wie zeigen der
anderen springern dass wir den
fallschirm öffnen und noch ganz viel
mehr es war eben 24 stunden im prinzip
zehn stunden am tag durchgehend theorie
prüfung aller not verfahren war zum
glück zum übungs vorrichtungen im hangar
aufgebaut wo wir das alles kontrollieren
konnten ein verdrehter fallschirm
bedeutet nicht gleich dass man den
fallschirm komplett karten muss sowie
slogan hall in seiner ausbildung gemacht
hatte
[Musik]
wir hängen sie da drin werden bilder
gezeigt bekommen wie der fallschirm dann
potenziell aussieht also ist er verdreht
haben wir in lofer also eine leine über
den fallschirm drüber ist der falsche
mann gerissen alles einmal
durchgesprochen und geschaut wie sie
reagieren da war immer die höhe im blick
und dafür sorgen dass man ruhig alleine
in dieser übung hat man nämlich gemerkt
dass man super krassen stress ausgesetzt
ist und genau dem gilt es vorzubeugen
damit wir in den situationen super ruhig
rational und objektiv einfach handeln um
das bestmögliche und am wenigsten
gefährliche ergebnis zu erzielen nun hat
1800 hamburg
keine möglichkeit irgendwas zu machen
lieber ein langsames und sauberer
durchgeführte notverfahren als active
innerhalb der gefühlt und das problem
verschlimmert
[Musik]
jetzt auch kurz dazu und warum oder wann
man den reserveschirm benutzen wenn der
fallschirm richtig kaputt ist oder mega
verdreht und man kann sich nicht lösen
gibt es ein paar szenarien wo man den
hauptschirm wirklichkeiten muss also man
geht an dieses cutaway handel zieht es
raus und der haupt fallschirm löst sich
quasi vom rucksack also man geht wieder
eine freifall phase und automatisch
öffnet sich der reserveschirm dann ist
alles gut und man landet alles bestens
das ist wird sie ins gesicht außerdem
ist der reserve fallschirm aber wie an
so ein mini computer angeschlossen der
sich im buch befindet und trägt ob man
zu schnell bei einer gewissen höhe fällt
würde man sich beispielsweise beim exit
aus dem flugzeug so sehr den kopf stoßen
dass man in ohnmacht fällt wird man
nicht einfach dem schicksal überlassen
sondern es zeigt was merkt okay er fällt
zu schnell in dieser bestimmten höhe und
löst quasi soweit ich weiß mit einem
sprengsatz den reserveschirm und man
landet richtig hier auch eine kleine
aufnahme davon vom cyrus youtube kanal
wo genau das passiert ist man sieht dass
die person wirklich komplett bewusstlos
ist sich gar nicht mehr bewegen kann ist
aus und alles gute personen kommen
sicher auf dem boden an
morgen wird es einen richtigen test
geben wo sich entscheidet ob wir den
sprung machen können oder nicht ein
bisschen aufgeregt aber eigentlich ganz
guter dinge das passt alles gibt im
prinzip drei vier szenarien die man im
kopf haben muss aber es ist jetzt kein
hexenwerk
tag nummer zwei heute geht es ans
eingemachte
heute werden wir in die luft gehen wir
checken jetzt gerade noch einmal alles
durch gelernt haben wir eigentlich alles
gestern heute geht es vielmehr darum ob
es wirklich verstanden haben ob wir es
verinnerlicht haben was mir aufgefallen
ist in der ausbildung geht super viel um
notverfahren risikoverhalten weil im
zweifelsfall alles nach plan
funktioniert also es ist tatsächlich gar
nicht so eine unsichere sportart oder
mega gutes wetter heute relativ wenig
wind also alles perfekt für den ersten
sprung hinter mir seht ihr die maschine
mit dem hoch fliegen werden wir machen
jetzt einmal noch alles durch und
dann geht's gleich anspringen was ganz
ganz ganz ganz verrückt von einem
subjektiven thema und den gedanken auch
mein gott ich springe aus einem flugzeug
das ist frei fall ist es über die
ausbildung hinweg zu einem super
objektiven thema geworden und so hoffe
ich das dann alles nach plan läuft aber
ich gehe fest davon aus und ich hab
megawatt wie ist denn der sieg schon
aussieht wird sich zeigen bestimmt noch
mal ein bisschen was anderes mit dem
ganzen stress und so aber ich glaube das
wird gut
also es geht los heute super wenig
gefilmt ich bin schon sehr in gedanken
muss ich sagen aber ziemlich ruhig und
ich glaube dass ich mir die ohren nehmen
würde wenn ich weiß dass filme ich freue
mich mega haben natürlich respekt aber
ich glaube das wird gut also ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass das alles
funktioniert aber ist natürlich schon
ein mulmiges gefühl ich geh jetzt auf
ein paar tausend meter
wenn alles klappt sehen fallschirm bei
1800 meter das landemanöver vernünftig
hinbekommen also freue mich wenn die
kamera jetzt ausgeht und ich das
gut über die bühne bringen wünscht mir
glück wir wechseln auf die kamera vom
instructor und nach 26 stunden theorie
also sorry für den titel ist waren
wahrscheinlich zwei stunden mehr vor
meinem ersten sprung dieses irgendwann
ready for take off ab ins flugzeug ab in
die luft alles noch mal kontrollieren
und den ersten sprung war
ich war unheimlich angespannt und ruhig
zugleich ich weiß nicht ob das irgendwie
sinn macht aber man sitzt schon eng an
eng in diesem flugzeug das ist jetzt
auch keinen platz um das alles dann noch
mal um zu koordinieren oder so das
bedeutet wenn man da drin sitzt weiß man
man wird gleich springt man geht
richtung fenster konzentriert sich und
probiert noch mal alles durch zu gehen
und das genauso zu machen die in uns
gelernt dachte ich zumindest denn ich
habe vom punkt eins an richtig verpackt
direkt beim absprung schienen alles
vergessen eigentlich muss man den
fluglehrern halt anzeigen wann man
rausspringen bilden und man macht das
über eine körperbewegung also 12 und auf
drei springt man raus das habe ich
direkt komplett vergessen
mega gefährlich mega scheiße aber das
ist der erste sprung das wurde mir auch
vorher gesagt und ich dachte mir ach
nein ich krieg das bestimmt besser hin
war nicht der fall ich habe einfach nach
draußen gepusht und die lehrer wussten
aber bestens damit umzugehen als wäre
das nicht schon genug man ist im
freifall man hat vorher besprochen
welche übungen machen soll ich hab da
gechillt und dachte mir ich habe ja zeit
cook rum und habe einfach meine übung
nicht gemacht welche hat mir irgendwann
angezeigt alter brawn macht man eine
übung wir sind hier im freifall du hast
nicht ewig zeit und dann habe ich
angefangen meine übung zu machen 3 test
griffe an den teile gut aber in diesem
moment schien wirklich alles wieder
vergessen dann wenn ich komplett rein
gekommen war aber natürlich ziemlich
instabil bei 1800 schüttelt man den kopf
das heißt no more work wave damit quasi
alle wissen okay man zieht jetzt seinen
teil schirm eröffnet sich
glücklicherweise richtig hängen da drin
und bin komplett überwältigt von
eingeführt wirklich das war unglaublich
man fängt an die ersten kurven zu ziehen
ein bisschen gefühl dafür zu bekommen
und ist einfach mega mega überwältigt
und sollte dann eigentlich im lande
patterns liegen habe ich überhaupt nicht
hinbekommen bin absolut abseits der
landes ohne geflogen und dann
schlussendlich tatsächlich in einem feld
gelandet aber ziemlich selbst alles gut
ich konnte auslaufen und bin mega
entspannt gelandet unglaublich wirklich
also völlig verrückte erfahrung noch mal
was ganz anderes dann im flugzeug zu
sitzen meine knie sind noch ein bisschen
weich aber nicht weil ich schiss habe
sondern weil ich so voll mit adrenalin
bin komplett unter strom stand der
moment an dem ich an die tür gegangen
bin war alles weg gehen weil sie wie die
letzten zwei tage eingetrichtert habt
sollte so nicht sein hat aber
unglaublich spaß gemacht und jetzt habe
ich nur noch mehr bock das alles zu
professionalisieren und alles vernünftig
zu machen und nicht mehr auf zwei leute
angewiesen zu sein die mir zeigen was
ich machen soll sondern dass immer immer
und immer wieder sicher und gut abrufen
zu können was soll ich euch erzählen ich
bin immer noch da ich habe direkt im
zweiten sprung gebucht ist muss
weitergehen
[Musik]
ich bin dann tatsächlich komplett
alleine gesprungen ich bin alleine
abgesprungen ich bin alleine stabil
geworden in der luft ich habe die
übungen machen können ich habe die
früher im blick ich habe selber einen
fallschirm gezogen der fallschirm geht
auf ich kontrolliere selber alles ich
fliege selber bin beim zweiten mal dann
auch wirklich vernünftige spiralen
geflogen also hat eine seite richtig
ordentlich runter gezogen und bin
richtige steilkurven geflogen das lande
pattern hat geklappt und ich bin
ungefähr 20 meter von seinem roten
extras auf dem boden lag perfekt gegen
den wind gelandet der in österreich das
vorstellen es ist 26 stunden jahren dass
ich den ersten fuß in diesen hunger
gesetzt habe ich bin nie aus einem
flugzeug gesprungen und plötzlich stehe
ich an der kante um das erste mal dass
sich mit eigener kraft herausspringen
soll bin ich quasi allein aber das war
trotzdem völlig in einem bugatti land
wie deutschland nach 26 stunden mit so
einem ding alleine daraus zu springen
völlig verrückt also es war ein
absoluter traum ich habe mega rock
weiterzumachen für die volle ausbildung
brauche ich 23 weitere sprünge wenn ihr
lust habt dass sich das weiter in
angriff nehmen wenn ihr lust habt es
weiter zu verfolgen dann lasst dem video
ein leichter vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren dann sehen wir uns in den
nächsten tagen wieder vielen dank an die
vielen dank an teilen des berlin-trip
ein voller erfolg und ich werde jetzt
scheinbar fallschirmspringer